Christene Blasi before testified she was
sexually assaulted by Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh when they were
both in high school Cavanaugh strongly
denied the claim much of yesterday's
hearing focused on the time when they
were teenagers so we decided to assemble
a panel of current Chicago area high
school students they shared their
thoughts with Adriana Diaz not only on
the allegations but the relevance of
these hearings for young people today
have you guys been paying attention to
the Brett Kavanaugh story I've been
following the reports on the news like
reading some articles about it
what do you think about it what stands
out to you I think it's the position of
power that we're trying to put them in
it's kind of like scary to see someone
who has like such serious allegations
beat up for a position like this is it
scary to be in high school knowing that
something you do now
can affect you in 3040 years absolutely
well I think that's part of like what's
so good about this like coming up is
that people should be scared that they
like their actions do have consequences
do you think it's fair to expect
teenagers to know right from wrong when
it comes to sexual harassment and
assault I think it's very fair I think
even as children as a 5 year old we have
this human intuition where we know right
from wrong
I think sexual harassment is like human
intuition you know that it's wrong to
assault someone I think kids in high
school maybe don't know whether it's
wrong or not to get drunk or to do that
kind of stuff but to physically harass
the person we've been taught forever
that it's wrong does a culture of
objectifying girls and women still exist
today in high school nothing has changed
I was even reading some of the articles
from 30-plus years ago and I definitely
think it's still the same I think that
that the way boys are supposed to act is
to pursue girls regardless of like how
they respond I think that's like a very
toxic part of our culture that persists
today what do you make of the whole
notion that boys will be boys I think
it's a childish excuse for something you
very well know that you were doing
at one point or another like at one
point or another he knows he was
drinking he knows he was getting drugged
I also think that like to a certain
point I think that it's yeah like boys
will be boys like girls will be girls
like it can be said about anyone but I
think it's really important that like
and people make mistakes and I think
it's important for them to like reflect
on their mistakes and like know like
that was a really stupid thing I did
like I shouldn't have done that like I
shouldn't have gotten drunk that night
like I shouldn't have done this to that
girl or whatever you just mentioned
drinking is alcohol abuse at parties by
your peers my you're shaking your head
and you're 15 I mean I don't think that
has changed either just I mean there's
new things there's new drugs maybe stuff
like that but I've been just abusing
something that's not meant to be abused
is definite high school thing it's like
people will go outside of their comfort
zone to be accepted because especially
in high school there's kind of a need
for acceptance among people like you
have to have somewhere to fit in
somewhere to be somewhere to like exist
where you feel comfortable even if you
have to start by making yourself
uncomfortable do you think young men are
more likely to be targeted or be assumed
guilty rather than assumed innocent I
can't speak from personal experience but
just looking at it from an outside
perspective absolutely I think with
something that's like as heavy a sexual
assault instead of it being innocent
until proven guilty it's more of a young
men start guilty until proven innocent
I thought we shouldn't start with the
mentality that they are guilty raise
your hand if you know someone who's been
sexually harassed or assaulted by a peer
do you want to describe what and
whatever you want you don't have to I
mean it just it happens at parties yeah
and it's serious it's very serious it's
it's something that makes like that as a
15 year old you don't know how to help
your friend you don't know what to do
and you just you kind of feel at a loss
where how could
this how could I let this happen I
wasn't even there but how could this
happen to someone that I know and to me
next you don't know I also think that
there are like some situations where it
does get really serious but there are
just some times when like a guy comes
out of the room and like high-fives all
his friends and it's something that that
like that that just like I don't know
that I like distinctly remembered of
being like oh like that just kind of
weird and you're saying you may not know
what happened behind closed doors yeah
but just the fact that like he comes out
in like that's his initial response I'm
like the girl like didn't come out with
him like was still in the room like
didn't see it happening but he comes out
looking for props yeah have you or
anyone you know had to help someone get
help or help them report what happened
was that hard for you or the person you
were helping it was definitely hard for
the person I was helping just because
there's so much pressure to not be like
the girl who like ruins his life my
friend has actually um not reported it
and she does not want to either and I
think it's because of exactly what is
what are you describing you don't want
to be the person to ruin his life or you
don't want to you don't want anyone to
know because it's so embarrassing to see
to imagine yourself so small and and I
think yeah tying in to the Brett
Kavanaugh case I think that I was just
imagining maybe 30 years she'll say
something about it and it if the fact
that it should take that long is just
yeah it's just kind of sad I really
appreciate their candor and their poise
at such a young age it just shows you
how little in some cases things have
changed yeah speak conversations with
boys with our sons and our daughters
about this topic right and on the one
hand you're a bit more optimistic
because they know what to look out for
and yet it still happens and they don't
want to hurt the boy or the girl you
know short term long term we know what
the implications are too though yeah
they've really but the the fact that
they were able to speak out it with such
clarity though gives me
hope it's very important conversation